good morning Jade a lot going on here in
Downing Street this morning now what's
happening is a reshuffle triggered by
the sacking eight days ago of Nadeem
zahawi he was the Dory party chair but
after thinking about about it for the
last few days the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak has decided to do quite a lot more
under the Bonnet tinkering with the way
that his government works which means
actually there's quite a medium-sized
reshuffle underway here in Downing
Street barely just over a hundred days
into his time in Downing Street here's
what we know this morning what he's
going to do is he's basically going to
split up quieter the a lot of the
economic business departments and move
some of the key elements around so he's
first of all going to create a new
energy security department now we
believe that Grant chat currently the
business secretary is in line to be the
Secretary of State in that department
and that's partly a response to the
enormous challenges that we're seeing
with energy bills Energy prices security
of energy Supply where she's seen that
of course making big promises in his
leadership contest about making sure
energy Supply is independent within a
matter of decades so that's the first
big change creating an energy Security
Department the next thing is he's going
to roll the department for international
trade of course uh well known as a
birthplace for figures like Liz truss
now that's actually going to be wrapped
into the remains of the business
department now we think that Kevin
basenot currently the trade secretary
wasn't to be on a mission uh out of the
country today we think that she is going
to become the new secretary of state for
business and trade and then the Third
change that Rishi sunak is going to make
to the way that Whitehall works is to
then bring together quite a lot of uh
the uh science Innovation and Technology
departments that's going to be probably
sitting under the Secretary of State
Michelle donalan she is in line for that
that job and we wait to hear who is
going to be in charge of the remains of
the culture Department that going back
to the way that it existed about five
years ago that'll just become the
department of culture media and Sport
once again having lost all of the
digital briefs and as for the job
vacated by Nadim zahawi well we expect
that to go potentially to Greg hands
veteran london-based conservative always
a frequently wheeled out media performer
so we have the shape of what looks like
the reshuffle this morning Rishi sunac
trying to focus in on what he identifies
the problems and key areas are of course
they're slightly different from the
public priorities that he talks about
endlessly his five public priorities but
uh I think you get a sense of the
importance to him of trying to promote
growth trying to protect energy security
and also focus in particular on digital
Industries where he hopes that growth is
going to come from in the months and
years to come now the cabinet meeting
that was expected this morning has been
pushed back we are told until this
afternoon we haven't had the traditional
walk up from cabinet ministers who are
being appointed it's been done behind
closed doors this morning I suspect that
reflects some of the complexity of
Simply reorganizing Whitehall
departments it sounds like an easy press
release actually behind the scenes it's
now going to mean months and months of
work of officials moving buildings uh
different people being put into
different teams actually that can slow
down the immediate delivery of some
priorities but this is government as
Rishi sunac wants it to be run and we'll
get the remaining details later in the
day